I need to start by telling you a little bit about my social life,...
...which I know may not seem relevant, but it is.
When people meet me at parties and they find out that I'm an English professor...
...who specializes in language, they generally have one of two reactions.
One set of people look frightened.
They often say something like, "Oh, I'd better be careful what I say.
I'm sure you'll hear every mistake I make."
And then they stop talking.
And they wait for me to go away and talk to someone else.
The other set of people, their eyes light up, and they say,...
"You are just the person I want to talk to."
And then they tell me about whatever it is...
...they think is going wrong with the English language.
A couple of weeks ago, I was at a dinner party...
...and the man to my right started telling me about all the ways...
...that the Internet is degrading the English language.
He brought up Facebook, and he said, "To defriend?
I mean, is that even a real word?"
I want to pause on that question: What makes a word real?
My dinner companion and I both know what the verb "defriend" means,...
...so when does a new word like "defriend" become real?
Who has the authority to make those kinds of official decisions about words, anyway?
Those are the questions I want to talk about today.
I think most people, when they say a word isn't real, what they mean is,...
...it doesn't appear in a standard dictionary.
That, of course, raises a host of other questions, including, who writes dictionaries?
Before I go any further, let me clarify my role in all of this.
I do not write dictionaries.
I do, however, collect new words much the way dictionary editors do,...
...and the great thing about being a historian of the English language...
....is that I get to call this "research."
When I teach the history of the English language,...
...I require that students teach me two new slang words before I will begin class.
Over the years, I have learned some great new slang this way,..
...including "hangry," which is when you are cranky or angry because you are hungry,...
....and "adorkable," which is when you are adorable in kind of a dorky way.